today on stick to football we are
breaking down the weekend baby we got
mellow we got Connor you can check us
out on Bleacher Report's YouTube page
guys we're gonna get into college
football with our picks we're gonna
blind review the Thursday night game
we're gonna talk a lot about the trades
we're also going to draft our top five
surprise Super Bowl teams so a lot of
college a lot of NFL but first some
announcements guys our London event the
details are in we we thank you for your
patience with this it's been there are
phones that work to call London but
we've had some issues with it so
O'Neill's Irish pub Sunday October 27th
Mela will be 32 years old but he will
not be there for four to six o'clock
they will have the NFL games on we'll be
watching them recording the podcast and
probably just getting smashed on pints
and then eating a ton of fish and chips
but also Alabama LSU if you don't live
in the UK we will be on the quad
November 9th Alabama hosting LSU this is
probably the game of the year in college
football we will be there a free
tailgate I already have people signing
up I would love it if y'all could DM us
and let us know you're coming because we
need to know how much food to order and
how much dress refreshments to buy yeah
oh yeah hit us in the DMS I'm so excited
for that game I am too I'm and not to
take anything away from the other stops
that we've been to LSU Texas was great
Madison I loved I truly loved that place
but this game just already has a
different feel to it it's gonna be a
number one to match up as long as these
two teams take care of business and I
really hope they do up until November
9th I'm very much rooting for LSU and
what they can do they I just pray that
both of them are undefeated when we go
see them yeah that's what I've been
holding on each week especially watching
LSU because they've had so many tough
opponents and they still have some ahead
where it's like please don't lose please
don't lose because if these two teams
face each other undefeated I mean the
hype around this game it's gonna almost
feel like a national championship game
in the beginning in November so we can't
wait to be at the quad we can't wait to
be in London please if you're coming to
either reach out to us let us know
you're gonna be there having more of an
idea of the numbers it helps us for
drinks food all that stuff we can't wait
now I know Matt
see something in this rundown and I have
no idea what it is so I'm gonna let you
take it away
well Melo just had a seizure now I don't
know what's what well Connor was talking
about this game this might be the best
game you see all year it might not be
the national championship game these
might be the two best teams that we have
in college football and you can go see
it in Alabama which is pretty much the
mecca of college football so if you're
not there you are really missing out
you're gonna have some serious FOMO
I just hope LSU takes care of Auburn
because if they don't but yeah this game
and it's not as big of a deal our ticket
prices are gonna drop alright yeah a
surprise addition to the rundown I
haven't told mello Connor about this but
last year right after Halloween I got
really upset because we should have
asked you guys to dress up as us because
that is how big my ego is but because of
that ego I'm gonna give you guys some
money dress up as your favorite or least
favorite stick to football host post a
picture on Twitter or Instagram or both
tag us in it the best costume I'm gonna
VIN mow you a hundred dollars out of my
own pocket best costume you just have to
dress up as a host and yes Mello this is
open to you yeah and I will retweet the
hell out of it I think I'm just gonna
find a way to dress up as Matt just be I
don't even know how we'd do that but I
will figure something out because if
it's a hundred bucks that's on the table
there's not a lot I wouldn't do for $100
that's a pretty easy hundred dollars I
mean you throw some pomade in your hair
or whatever you want to do you want to
start tweeting like a dad then you got
the Matt costume down right this is an
easy hundred bucks right here just
carrying case of natty around with a
Texas jogger and your mellow boom I mean
yeah it's that simple yeah it's really
that easy all right let's get into the
actual show guys a ton of trades this
week it starts with Jalen Ramsey finally
being moved the Los Angeles Rams swoop
in they send a 2020 first round pick a
2021 first and a 2021 fourth round pick
to Jacksonville to get a 24-year old
corner who has shut down caliber I won't
know what you guys think of this trade
and that and also not only for
Jacksonville to move on from him but for
the Rams to give up so many picks so I
think this is a win-win situation for
both teams
think that the Rams go out there three
and three right now they're sitting
there saying we have to turn this around
go get the best shutdown corner in the
league I love what they're doing there
but I also love it from the Jag
standpoint because they're going and
getting a lot of first-round picks you
have Gardner Minshew who might be your
future there at quarterback now you can
surround him with some other pieces yeah
you're giving up a corner who's great
and I love Ramsey but you can also go
get another receiver or some other
pieces on this defense that set you up
for a year to year three of this Gardner
Minshew era I really like it too I look
at this trade and I think there are like
Melo said there's a way both teams can
win now the big one for me and this has
been this has been the opposite on
Twitter Twitter and everyone really
values these first rounders a lot more
than I personally do when the pics are
in the 20s maybe 30s I look at this Rams
team I know they're three and three I
know Jared Goff has struggled recently a
lot of things have gone wrong for them
but I still think this is one of the
best teams in football and I still think
they could be one of the best teams in
football for the next two to three years
where they're not going to be pay it's
not like the Steelers sending a first
rounder for making Fitzpatrick that's
gonna be probably a top ten pick on the
Jacksonville side you should stockpile
picks the relationship was done between
him and Tom Coughlin that's a shame I
really do have some problems with that
you've seen Doug morones frustrations in
press conferences already but I like the
move for each side I don't think it's an
people look at all those picks go wow
that's a lot this is a 24 year olds one
of the top corners who plays it was a
great attitude on the field I think he's
gonna bring a different kind of you know
electric energy to this Ram secondary
and hopefully reignite them for the rest
of the season
yeah guys the excuse me puberty hit the
lead to my scouting notebook article
this week is about the team's
willingness to trade first-round picks
and I think that we see that now we see
the Rams do it we see the Texans trade
it for the best left tackle in football
yes it cost them two first-round picks
but oh well their offensive line wolves
are solved amazing how that works so I
believe this is win-win for both if the
jaguars hit on these picks right now
they would own six and 16 in the first
round
those aren't easy pics to hit and I
think you can look at the success rate
of first round picks
it's about 50% the success rate of Jalen
Ramsey that's 100 percent so maybe I'm
just conservative as a general manager
or maybe this is not concerned because
you're trading first-round picks but I
would rather go for the proven 24 year
old shut down corner or the proven 23
year old left tackle over the potential
of a draft pick like you said I'm not
sound picks as everyone else yeah I
think it just comes down to how you want
to work your salary cap do you want to
pay that much to a quarter or do you
want to try to go out and find your own
guy that you can control for like the
first five years of his career
I want to penalize which is very
difficult to do I mean paying Jalen
Ramsey there's a reason why you're
paying him you know what he can do you
know what he is on the field yeah yeah
they didn't give up they didn't give up
to first-round picks for a running back
or a linebacker yeah you know I mean
this is cornerback the premium positions
in the NFL and we said on the show year
after year starts with quarterback but
then you look at pass rushers offensive
tackles and corners because of how
difficult the position is to play in
today's NFL yep and speaking of corners
to do this the Rams traded Marcus Peters
which open up some salary cap space this
was kind of the precursor to the deal
Marcus Peters a very talented player a
little bit enigmatic he will be a free
agent after this year it looked like the
Rams were not interested in reciting him
long term so they go ahead and trade him
they get in exchange for him
Kenny young and then also a 2020 fourth
round pick so they pick up an extra pick
and also get a linebacker who was a very
good athlete coming out of UCLA but also
a player I had a ranked as a day seven
day seven around seven pick just because
of you know instincts he's been a
healthy scratch at times for the Ravens
but they feel a potential need for speed
on defense and they get rid of a guy who
I think could be a little bit of a
locker room problem we've seen that in
Kansas City if he's not happy with how
things are going yeah I mean he's he's
had his fair share of run-ins with
defensive coordinators and teammates so
I understand moving him especially as
soon as this happened I think everybody
on Twitter at least blew up is like if
you're moving on from Marcus Peters you
must have a play for Jalen Ramsey so I
think because of the Jalen Ramsey trade
I'm on board with the Marcus Peters one
you wouldn't want to give up a great
corner unless you have another one
coming in so I love what the Rams did
they shipped a guy out dumped some
salary bring in another corner who's
probably who is even better and plus you
get a little bit of return for it it's
not just a salary dump
Kenny young could be potentially good
and fill in over austere spot there I
don't he's not a difference maker but
when you tie everything in with the
Jalen Ramsey train I think it looks good
for the Reims
yeah and I'll take the Ravens side of it
here I really like it for them they're
not absorbing any long-term money he's a
free agent after this year Marcus Peters
play mat you alluded to this right off
the top it's been all over the place
sometimes he'll have a game where you
think he's a top five corner in the NFL
and sometimes he'll have a game where he
should be put on the bench that's how
Marcus Peters play now Baltimore they
develop players in the secondary they
also signed some good ones Tony
Jefferson I know he's hurt now but Earl
Thomas they have pieces in that
secondary where if you can get Marcus
Peters if you can get him right for this
year in a dogfight of a division right
now with Cleveland and the Ravens going
back and forth I like it because it's a
risk worth taking
that has no long-term repercussions if
it doesn't work out it is kind of weird
Peters picked off Garoppolo last week in
there all right see you buddy jaylen
ab/c adios last trade the Rams made they
didn't make three ones this week Austin
Corbett who was the 33rd pick of the
2018 NFL Draft traded to the Rams from
the Browns where he could not break this
lineup and it's interesting that I did
not value him this highly I did have him
I believe as a late round 2 or early
round 3 player in that 2018 draft class
he was an athlete who just needed
developed coming out of school so I
think that you look at the Rams since he
made a different offensive scheme maybe
they value more of an athlete more
agility in the middle of the offensive
line because this is a big big problem
for them when you look at team needs for
the Rams it's offensive line so if he
can fix one of those guard spots that's
huge for them especially a guy I believe
it was a 2021 5th rounder it's what they
said was so not you know we've talked
before guys but I go Brett Veatch does
this trade for Reggie Ragland trade for
kamerlingh this is kind of that same
mindset of okay you were valued as the
33rd pick in the 2018 draft we're gonna
and a fifth-round pick for you that is
the epitome of you know low-risk
potentially high return yeah and I think
that you're right when you say that he
can come in and maybe provide some depth
to this team obviously Cleveland wasn't
working out but how many times have we
seen a player move on to a different
situation like what he's doing and then
Excel and it may be not go on to be a
Pro Bowler or one of the best centers in
the league but at least have a revived
career and maybe he can do that it just
wasn't working out in Cleveland yeah
talk about a bad ROI here when your
return on investment is that low after
taking a guy top 40 not that long ago
it's clearly it clearly wasn't working
in Cleveland I think the player was over
drafted but at the same time the
development hasn't been there I like the
Rams offensive step and I know people
say well of course Shawn McVeigh and
everyone from it gets hired but I think
they have the right assistant coach is
there to maybe get this guy right where
they have enough offensive line problems
you're throwing a pick that won't be
used from now two years from now is when
we'll see that fifth round or use I like
it it's a flier but it's one that's
worth it the Rams are they're loading up
to win now if they don't want a Super
Bowl in the next few years we can look
back and say okay those were dumb trades
but they were there last year they were
in the game they've got like a solid two
three year window at least I think which
it you should feel good about if you're
a Rams fan I understand all these people
take it from me I'm a Jets fan I have
not seen a Super Bowl the team usually
has a losing season way more often than
not it should feel good to have the
opportunity to go for it not who cares
about the draft picks go for wins that's
why you play in this league go for Super
Bowls it's it's crazy to me how often
people overlook that I love that less
than a - I'm very like yeah we're gonna
swing the bat they want to win well yeah
that's good all right guys I'll actually
want to address something that popped up
on Wednesday mellow and I were having a
delicious dinner at the Olive Garden
which that is not an ad rewind okay and
the bread I didn't even get to enjoy any
of the bread because this happened so
we're at dinner and I get a I get a text
from Oregon head coach Mario Cristobal
and I know you're thinking that humble
Gregg nope he was not happy with me I
put out an article earlier this week a
draft stock while and it was scouts
quotes which you know it's like that's a
big part of us being on the road talking
to scouts building relationships so I
quoted a couple Scouts and a former
Oregon staff member the piece they were
very critical Justin Herbert which if
you listen to the show once twice three
times a week you're gonna know that we
have shared that opinion multiple times
that Scouts do not like this player they
think he's soft they don't think he's
tough coach Cristobal strongly disagrees
with that opinion and so I put out a
little statement on Instagram and
Twitter and just let people know that
coach Cristobal has said that Justin has
one of the highest football IQs he's
ever been around he's a competitor he
believes he's the best quarterback in
the country he referenced the fact that
he's only throw one pick this year so I
just wanted to because I feel like you
know I'm not gonna write an article and
then come on my podcast and I go let's
just ignore it so I just thought I'd
open the floor fish you guys have any
questions or if we just wanted to say
anything about this just a part of the
job like you're gonna piss people off I
I know the scouts that I talked to I
sent them a text I was like hey you're
gonna see this on Twitter
coach Cristobal was not happy about this
but again this is not I don't think this
is a you like a one rogue scout who has
this opinion yeah and you have to cut it
what's Cristobal supposed to do in this
situation he's got to go to bat for his
guy so I didn't worry about Washington
that's what I would do exactly because
we're gonna preview that game later uh
he's going to bat for his guy I guess a
lot of people will love that and respect
that about him but at the same time
somebody had this opinion it's not your
opinion because you've gotten into that
problem before yes just reporting what
you hear and I think that a lot of
people are interested in that to hear
what other Scouts in the NFL are saying
about a guy that could be the top
prospect they caught top quarterback in
this class Matt did Elise end well with
him it did it ended very well we Tex
good for a long time last night and it
ended with he respects the work I do he
appreciates the work I do but yeah he
and you know he's gonna he's gonna go to
bat for his guy who has a huge game this
weekend you know and and I pointed out
to him in the same article Scouts were
down on Jacob Eason who's playing
quarterback on the
it's out of the field this week so it
wasn't just a shot at Oregon this week
whoo I mean it took us 12 weeks last
year to finally be like you know what
yeah Kyler Murr you can probably play
football so like it'll be okay
people have their ups and their downs
but this week not great for Justin
Herbert go ball out against Washington
you will be just fine
all right well on top of that we talked
about one whatever story you know kind
of die it's a tough one too a very fun
story it is time mister mellow for the
blind review and it was a great Thursday
night because the Kansas City Chiefs
finally get back on track this offense
looks great Pat mahomes is 100% healthy
throws for five touchdowns the running
game looks great Tyreke is back I'm so
excited to be sitting here on a Friday
after a huge Chiefs win please God let
this come true mellow sets the table for
the blind review and I have to follow
that so here we go mahomes goes back to
the place where we first realized that
he could be a starting NFL quarterback
in seventeen degree weather in 2017 he's
at they're throwing no-look passes he's
thrown the lefty in Denver we saw them a
home's magic last night yes they miss
Eric Fisher but the Broncos miss Bradley
Chubb I think that was the difference on
Thursday night yeah I'm feeling really
good on this Friday because not only did
I bet on the Chiefs
as three and a half favorites in this
one I have a season-long bet Matt was
with me in Vegas my home's over/under I
took the over 36 and a half touchdowns
on the season Simoni after those five
last night I'm not even sweating this
one at all Pat mahomes is back stop
doubting him stop down the Chiefs and
the Broncos they're gonna stay in our
draft conversation going forward
all right the Chiefs are back and we'll
be back after this it is time to break
down the week of college football we're
gonna preview and pick them I fell
behind a game last week I am 27 and 13
Melos 28 and 12 Connors 21 and 9 as
always he got a late start on this it's
not like we just let him erase them game
that would be fantastic let's start here
in the sec number 9 Florida looking to
bounce back after that loss to LSU the
play at South Carolina who just upset
Georgia I don't I didn't put the
over-under in this week because I was
busy today let me just tell you South
Carolina will not win this game they
just they just dated the hottest girl in
school and she does like there's no way
they're next one's gonna be hotter
you're not gonna do that two weeks in a
row I'm sorry the line on this one is
negative five for Florida and I actually
think that's way too close for a lot of
those same reasons Florida bouncing back
off of a loss last week it's gonna be
ready to play South Carolina is feeling
themselves now they feel like they can
take on anybody but since they upset
Georgia
Florida's really gonna come into this
game and take it seriously I think that
if South Carolina would have just gotten
rolled by Georgia maybe they could upset
Florida at home I just don't see that
happening South Carolina really had a
lot of brakes go their way with the
turnovers with some missed field goals I
don't think we're gonna see that against
Florida I think that they're gonna come
ready to play I would even take the
points in this one I'm going Florida
with at least a seven point one yeah
sorry South Carolina fans I'm a doubter
right now for this one I think Florida
just they didn't get embarrassed they
hung with possibly the best team in the
country right now an LSU team at LSU
probably the toughest place to play in
college football I think they're gonna
go to South Carolina and I whoa this is
much better
Florida rolls yeah Florida rolls this
week I think they cover as well here's
the big one
at least on the west coast number 12
Oregon at number 25 Washington Conner
has seen Washington a person this
secondary is young they are a vicious
sieve and wash up flies around the ball
Jacob Eason has been a hot and cold this
year he has looked unstoppable against
bad teams stoppable against good teams
the line on this Oregon - three and I am
taking the Ducks in this one on the road
I just feel like that offensive line is
too good Justin Herbert has done a good
job protecting the ball this year I
don't love the skill players for the
Ducks so even like Washington's good
secondary like Oregon's receivers suck
anyway it's like Washington's corners
being good I feel like that's a bit of a
push for me so I am taking Oregon in
this one I I don't know they'll cover
but I think they win yeah and this is
where I'm gonna slide in my super
underdog locksmith game of the week too
your money on because I don't have the
nuts to bet my own money on Washington
is somehow the underdog in this game I
don't get it going to Washington is a
very tough place to play they're just
loud in that entire state
I like the Huskies in this one organ you
look at what they've done in their last
couple games they really haven't got it
done against any good defenses they're
putting up a lot of points on Colorado
on Montana in Nevada now you have to go
and face a good defense they're going to
struggle to put up points and their
defense hasn't really stopped anyone yet
they haven't played anyone so I like the
Huskies in this one I think that
whichever quarterback comes out on top
we have to start talking about more
seriously as a draft prospect alot going
down in this game Washington desperately
needs a win there at home I'm taking the
underdogs I love that pick Melo I
actually put in a real bet for
Washington to cover at two and a half I
mean I am a little surprised that this
game almost isn't really a pick'em to be
completely honest with you I'm going
with the Huskies I think this is a great
test for Justin Herbert whether it's
Myles Bryant Elijah Molden they have a
lot of players in that second secondary
that are tough they'll get their hands
on you with the line of scrimmage they
will look to take away the football I
like the Huskies in this one if Jacob
Eason can just not turn the ball over
and keep this game under control the
Washington should win big if their boys
big number is Taylor at Oklahoma State
Stillwater is a tough place to play that
is why the Cowboys are favored - for the
over/under in this one a 68 I'm taking
Oklahoma State and here's the big caveat
Spencer Sanders cannot turn the ball
over and I know that sounds obvious but
when he has protected the ball they've
won ballgames turn around and hand it to
Trubel Hubbard Baylor cannot stop him or
if you have to dump the ball off to him
out of the back field because Chuba
should be a Heisman candidate he is one
of if not the best running back in
college football right now this is
simple give it to Hubbard yeah I agree
with you the guy already has 1,000 yards
this year in just six games protect your
young quarterback with an amazing
running back with a guy out at receiver
in Thailand Wallace do some quick passes
get to get this offense going
and then you can kind
unleash Baylor I'm not a fan of because
I think they've struggled against some
teams like Texas Tech last week not a
great defense there I like what Oklahoma
State can do I think they can score
points and I think that Baylor the only
reason why we're looking at a six of no
team is because they're very untested I
know they beat Iowa State that was a
good win it was very close though
I think Oklahoma State wins this one
fairly easy not so fast boys I'm going
with Baylor here and listen I wish Matt
rule was coaching my New York Jets
instead but he is not he is still at
Baylor he is still undefeated I think
they go into a very tough place to play
and play very good defense to win this
game I will say the Baylor beat Texas
Tech Oklahoma State lost to them and
their last time we saw them before a bye
so a little bit of I know that never
correlates but it's at least something
to talk about number 17 Arizona State at
number 13 Utah the fighting Herm Edwards
man they just keep getting it done every
frickin week now Utah's a team we all
liked a lot in the preseason they
struggled early on there's that loss to
USC where Michael Pittman jr. just
absolutely went off in this game it's a
five o'clock central kick so it's an
afternoon game in Utah
I actually think Arizona State can go in
there and pull off the upset now Utah's
favored by 13 and a half so this is my
super dog locking this game of the week
I don't actually get to do that but I
should because I think Arizona State
pulls off the upset now I don't like the
points in this one thirteen and a half
because I think Arizona State can keep
them close with that defense they've
been playing pretty well defensively
they gave up a lot of points to
Washington State but that's Washington
State that's what you're gonna do there
I'm going with Utah though I still love
this team and I still think that they
come out as the winner in the pac-12 I
love the way that Tyler Hundley has been
playing lately they're a little bit
banged up but like you guys talked about
injuries just kind of happen and you
have to play through them so I like the
depth here and this defense against a
very young Arizona State quarterback I'm
gonna be taking the Utes these guys are
gonna be out ready to go I'm sorry that
the Utah fans don't get that extra four
hours of tailgating that you're used to
but I think that you talk and still
bring the noise and the get job done
yeah this is a pretty big line
I will say something and I am fully
guilty of it we do' and the national
media really doesn't give her mad words
enough credit for the job he's done
various / wonderful when he walked into
this program it was neared levels of
[ __ ] and now it is a top 20 team that
is there in every game I mean I like it
so great for her med words great for
Arizona State well done I hate to say it
though I'm going with Utah come on now
look at that defense I think that
performance against USC was a fluky game
I don't understand what happened to them
I haven't seen them look like that in
any other game this year I think they'll
get right back on track here and roll at
home that's the big thing here two guys
they're at home they'll be ready to play
Utah all the way yeah there's a big
running back game you know Benjamin and
Zac Moss two guys who could not be more
not alike less alike there we go Utah
defense though is really gonna get after
the quarterback to Daniel's has
struggled he's been getting sacked a lot
I know he's put up a lot of numbers this
is not a defensive line that you want to
try to test they've got some guys on
there they can really play so that's why
I'm sticking with you talking right the
last one number 16 Michigan they have
been hot lately but at number seven Penn
State the white out will be in effect
and guys I'm taking Penn State in this
one which these are like the two schools
that I've been the most down on and
probably been the most wrong about over
the last two years I just really did not
see Penn State being able to bounce back
from posts a Quan Post trace McSorley
post mile Sanders they're still just
winning football games they're favored
by nine in this one Melo's boy Sean
Clifford just keeps going off
KJ hammer might be small but he makes
big plays every Saturday I don't think
Michigan can slow down Penn State enough
to win this game no and I'm gonna agree
with you I like Penn State here I like
their defense I did not expect to like
this Penn State team as much as I did
which is why I was very hard on Sean
Clifford in the beginning of the year it
looks like he can play I know both
offenses have struggled against Iowa but
I do think that this offense for Penn
State can put up points I think it's
gonna be a close game but I think that
the difference is going to be a guy like
KJ hammer the receiver at Penn State
make a big play and that could be the
diff
so it could be a 14-13 type ballgame
here but Penn State has more of those
game-breaker home run threat guys and I
just haven't seen it from the Michigan
offense and I hate to piss off our
Michigan fans scored 42 points against
Illinois does not impress me scoring 52
against Rutgers not working for me I'm
looking at the game where you can only
score 24 points against army 14 against
Wisconsin and 3 points against Iowa you
got to get something gone with this
offense it was supposed to be the
strength of your season this year with
these receivers with a senior
quarterback Penn State is not gonna make
it any easier with guys like Michael
Parsons running around we've been very
harsh on this Michigan team this year
and I think this actually will be a
close game I still have to go with Penn
State because after seeing that Michigan
front get destroyed by Wisconsin I know
Penn State is not Wisconsin Penn State
is a very good football team and they
can run the ball they are tough I think
I was way too low on them they are a
very for real top 10 team I am excited
for a potential Penn State Ohio State
matchup here down the line I like this
Penn State team I like watching them
play they win in different ways and
that's that matters so much in the big
10 so Michigan is walking into a bit of
a buzz saw in this game I don't think
they'll embarrass themselves but there
is no way I could see them pulling off
the upset it is top five time in today's
topic is the top five surprise Super
Bowl team so don't give me your Chiefs
Niners Patriots basically all my team's
yeah there you go hand em up with those
three right weird I'm good at picking
football teams and I get to go first
because I think we're going in age order
maybe I don't know what we're doing so
sure pick I am going to take the
Baltimore Ravens and I know that there's
maybe this is a controversial pick
because they're four and two they're
running away with the AFC North they
would be a surprise because I thought
this team would suck this year I did not
think that their what they have a
receiver I didn't think it would be
enough they kind of got him running back
by committee thing going they lost CJ
Moseley they just did not look to me
like a team that was ready to make this
type of run oh they have Lamar Jackson
is playing at an incredible clip even
with injuries on the defensive side of
the ball they're still getting it done
the Ravens are my number one pick is
surprised
is you took the Raven so they're off the
board you talk about quarterbacks that
have struggled and maybe they are
playing outside of the expectations I'm
gonna take the Minnesota Vikings here
and Kirk Cousins this student has been
playing outside of his mind lately I
think that this defense is in place the
receivers are amazing Dalvin cook like
looks like a different running back than
what we saw early in his career he's
healthy I actually think the Vikings
here can make a strong push maybe even
get on top of their division and make a
run in the playoffs
alright now I'm going with a bit of at
the mat route Here I am taking a team at
the top of their division but I don't
think people are picking the Texans to
be in the Super Bowl and I'll tell you
why I do think they can sneak in I think
the Shawn Watson can win you any
football game on any given day I think
it's as simple as that I think he is in
line for an MVP award this season I
really do I think this team is only
getting you know getting more momentum
new offensive line pieces in play will
fuller is back there's a lot to like
about the Texans now as we go down this
top five the chances of these teams is
going to get drastically worse so I'll
start with one that is quietly having a
great year now and you actually get to
go again the beauty of the snake' draft
is you know let's see let's bring it
back okay I also kind of hate this pick
because I feel like it's become super
obvious with the move they just made but
let's talk about the Rams they are 3-3
things are things are not good right now
with Jared Goff the Todd Gurley is hurt
that's been a key storyline but even at
3 and 3 even trailing the undefeated
49ers I think Sean McVeigh will get this
team right I still think they win 11
games they are they'll be fine I'm not
worried about them at all Aaron Donald
is the best football player probably on
planet earth the things he could do so
the Rams it's crazy to talk about a team
to be a surprise that was just in the
Super Bowl but they are three and three
right now they got some catching up yeah
I agree with you they definitely would
have been one of my picks I'm gonna stay
with Connors NFC East here I'm going
with the Buffalo Bills I really like
this tee
I like the way that they're built and I
actually I don't think they're playing
their best football yet they're still
sitting there four and one just behind
the Patriots and they played them pretty
well so far this year so I'm gonna go
with the bills I know that Josh Allen's
young I'm not his biggest fan he turns
the ball over a lot all you needs one
game one game where he can just go out
ball out not turn the ball over and you
can win the Super Bowl I mean you can do
it with this running game plus I just
want to see Frank Gore get one how are
you not Josh Allen's biggest fan when
you have a tattoo of him well we can't
confirm that he doesn't have it he had
one he just secretly went and got is
where it happened and there to cut it
off yeah right the spider bite was
actually a tattoo and then it got really
infected learn all right my second pick
I can't believe they were still on the
board I want to take the Seattle
Seahawks I think they are only getting
better if the shell Watson doesn't win
MVP Russell Wilson probably will he has
been for real I want to see what happens
with will dis Lee going down I think
they really were relying on him in the
passing game but the defense is good
enough the coaching is obviously good
enough and the quarterback is a
superstar now coming back around to me
I'm gonna take the Dallas Cowboys I know
that the shine has fallen off this team
a little bit the last few weeks I mean
[ __ ] they lost to the Jets guys so
they're not looking fantastic but if
they can get back on pace with dak WizIQ
if they can just get healthy with Amari
Cooper
Mikel gallop I think there are enough
pieces there and the NFC East is just
bad right now so they could back their
way into the playoffs and maybe make a
run you're just trying to piss off every
Jets fan every time he gets a chance
alright I'm gonna go with another
surprise team led by a young quarterback
because that's the trend I'm going with
here the Carolina Panthers I'm on board
with this Kyle Allen stuff I think that
he's playing very well this year I had
the running game with Christian
McCaffrey obviously couldn't Excel the
defense doesn't look too bad either
I wouldn't be surprised if they even
bring in some more guys I really like
the Panthers and even though Kyle Allen
went to Texas A&M
he left there so I can root for him I
like what they're doing I I think that
Cam Newton once he gets back in he's
healthy he needs to step up on board as
a guy as a locker room guy that brings
this team together to set them over the
edge I think that it could be a surprise
pick for the Super Bowl all right this
is where it starts to get fun I am
taking in our third round here to cap
off our third round the Detroit Lions
who got jobs against the Green Bay
Packers I think the Packers right now
are probably one of the best teams in
football
you will not see them on this top five
because they are not available for us to
pick because they're too good the Lions
they've hung with the Chiefs they've
hung with the Packers some would say
they got cheated out of a win against
the Packers listen we were harsh on him
over summer I think nobody has given
them love I thought Matt Patricia would
find a way to get himself fired this
year wrong wrong wrong the Lions are
doing everything they can to prove
people wrong and even though that only
amounts to a 2-2 in one record right now
I love having them on that list because
at least they're showing week to week
that they won't be embarrassed by anyone
they're gonna hang tough with everyone
my next pick here I'm going with the
Indianapolis Colts now when you watch
what this team is doing it's an absolute
bummer because you sit there and you go
man if they had Andrew Luck that what
would it be like but at least they're
staying competitive week to week this
roster that Chris Ballard and Edie Dodds
have built is a very competitive roster
the offensive line is very very good
Marlin Mack looks like a different
player all of a sudden Jacoby percent
has not fallen apart so the Colts right
now it's not talked about often but
they're hanging around that's a vision
yeah well Connor just took everything
that I was about to say so I hope that
it was all good I'm scrambling to find a
different team here I'm gonna go with
the Philadelphia Eagles maybe not that
big of a surprise but again this is a
team that's sitting three and three
they're third in their own division not
looking great so if maybe they're tied
for the I don't want to get that wrong
cuz Eagles fans will kill me they are
tied they're second in the division
right now I think that I their path
going through the Giants the Redskins
that should be some wins the Cowboys I
don't know who they are anymore after
they lost to a very
a very good jet steam because I love the
jet and they play very good football in
New York but I think the Eagles are a
team that have been there before even
though it wasn't Carson wins they could
get on track and if they're just healthy
if they are healthy they're one of the
best teams in the NFC you know the
Eagles should actually do trade for Nick
Foles right just bring him back I don't
know if you guys saw because we had just
sat down to record but Justyna anderson
from ESPN had a quote from an Eagles
player an unnamed Eagles player that was
like we need to simplify some [ __ ]
because like even Peyton Manning knew to
check down at the end of his career like
they kind of went at went anonymously of
course but still so I may be talking
that locker room before though about
players not liking Carson Wentz
yeah this comes around every once in a
while and I would love for somebody to
do a full story on it because it's
unexplainable but there's something to
tie down on this story yes that yeah he
might kill it number four for me
speaking of trading Nick Foles give me
that Minshew mania in Miami
the Jags as I don't even know if it'd be
a surprise if they made it at this point
this is he I mean they have played
everyone closely at this point they're
two and four but their point
differential is only minus 14 I think
the loss of Jalen Ramsey getting rid of
some of that attention I think this team
could be galvanized by it they could
rally around it Leonard fournette been
playing very well I love their young
receiver core especially DJ shark I
think Minshew is just starting to heat
up so again this like we're 16 deep
right now on a surprise team Stone don't
tweet me and be like you're right you
know an idiot I know this is highly
improbable but I'm here for it and my
last team I don't know if the Chicago
Bears can be fixed but I know the
defense is good enough that if they
could just score nine points they could
probably win a lot of football games
Hakeem Hicks going out it's huge but you
still have Khalil Mak you still have
Kyle foolery stuff Eddie Jackson Roe
Kwan Smith is back this is a team that
has so much potential on defense if
someone offensively could just do
something it feels like they could start
to make a run in an NFC North that is
they're not that far behind right now
they're a game back or excuse me two
games back they can still make some
noise
fellas we are digging through the trash
here now I got a team here so I'm gonna
go with the Los Angeles chargers
because I like philip rivers they have
no [ __ ] chance to win the Super Bowl
there too and for their best defensive
players hurt in Derwin James may be the
edge rushers can get something going and
they can get Melvin Gordon back that
will help maybe I don't know I'm gonna
say the Chargers alright for the last
one here this is gonna surprise some
people but I'm gonna go with the Miami
Dolphin they're gonna be in the toilet
bowl this year but speaking to the
toilet bowl I'm going with the Cleveland
Browns here the Browns have a Superbowl
caliber roster and an XFL level head
coach right now so if they let Todd
Monken take over they might be able to
rip off some wins in all seriousness
Baker needs to get right I don't think
just trading a million assets for Trent
Williams is necessarily the answer to
that there are more problems with this
team but listen we're in the final pick
of this little draft we're doing here in
terms of on paper Talent the Browns have
as much of it as anyone they just don't
look ready week to week
it is draft on draft time and God we got
to start putting like a we just need a
little cooler right here with beer we
need to start having beers again during
draft on traffic we work at night
there's average rate that people can see
me pointing right there with old beer in
it like I don't know if this will be the
last Thursday night that we don't have
beers during draft a sick of it you
don't have to talk me into drinking
everyone knows did you see by the way
there's a Waffle House in Atlanta that's
gonna start selling beer okay how will
we survive the Senior Bowl if this
becomes nationwide how will we survive
just society in general if we're getting
drunk people more alcohol at Waffle
House yeah that's that's a great idea
for Waffle House an awful idea for
America let me just keep getting drunk
and ordering more hash browns with gravy
on them like we already see people just
passed out there
I guess now they won't be passed out not
pointing fingers alright let's get into
the actual questions from Adam [ __ ]
would Cardell have been a first rounder
after just three games starting at Ohio
State this Cornell Jones 2016 NFL Draft
no he would not have been I know that
this is like the Matt Barkley would have
been a first
had he left after a junior year no he
would not have been he was just hyped
because we hadn't dug into him yet
Cardale would have been slaughtered for
only starting three games now he might
have been drafted higher than the fourth
round where he ultimately ended up but
there is no way in hell if you go back
to that 2015 draft that this man would
have been a first-round pick
not so fast there Matty Paxton Lynch
went in the first round of this draft
and I hate to do this to you Connor but
also Christian Hackenberg was drafted in
the second round of that same draft
I think Cardale Jones his arm alone
would have put him in the first round I
don't think that would have put him into
a great situation where we would be like
oh my God look at cardiology owns today
like he's probably still gonna end up in
the XFL but i actually do think he would
have went in the first round there's so
much of what I think happens with the
draft is where is your stock are you HOT
are you rising because that helps your
draft stock if not then you probably
should go back to school but I I do
think that he would have went in the
first round yeah I think the interviews
and the board work work would have been
really interesting for him because I
think he even admitted that he I don't
know if he was ready for that yet he
needs another year to go back and on the
flip side if you read the latest ty Dunn
piece about the shaun watson that was
something in aspect of his game that
blew away the texans how great his board
work was and they were like okay this is
the guy we could take this guy so that
stuff matters so much but like Melo said
it only takes one maybe somebody comes
back in at the end of the first like the
Ravens did for Lamar Jackson and they
say hey we're gonna go back in before
anyone could take this guy at the top of
day two we'll never know my gut says he
would not have been but at the end of
the day he definitely unfortunately hurt
his stock by going back to school yeah
I've said before scouting quarterback
starts in January because it's so much
of the board work the character of the
injury history you know and we've seen
it the last couple senior bowls guys
really shoot up the board right Todd
rice wants to know guys when making mock
drafts the team I struggle with most is
my favorite team the Seattle Seahawks
how do you guys make predictions for
teams like to see hawks and Patriots
they'll often go against common draft
wisdom so it's really really hard I will
say if you want to do a mock draft in
April and get those teams right you need
to be a little bit plugged in like a
couple years ago I had Malcolm Brown of
the Patriots for about a month
that wasn't look like that someone's
telling you hey they're gonna draft this
guy he's available otherwise as like a
fan or what I try to do this time of
year is I will look at like the Seahawks
are not gonna draft a corner the
Patriots are not going to draft well
they've kind of flipped everything no
generally they're not you know draft
like a linebacker a defensive lineman I
know they Michael Brown was the one they
did take but now they've kind of gone to
a strategy of piecing those together
through free agents or mid to late round
picks but the Patriots have drafted a
running back in the first round they've
drafted a tackle in the first round
receiver and receiver
they are diversifying which makes it a
little bit harder yeah I think it is
really hard with those two teams
specifically because you don't know what
they're gonna value they might take a
guy like Rashard Penny in the first
round even though a lot of people didn't
expect it so those are actually two
teams that I really struggle with too a
lot of times they're picking at the end
of the first round and since they're
already so good a lot of times I'll just
go best player available for both of
them
yeah you look at the Seahawks they have
a pretty consistent trend of drafting
very they're very heavy on D line the
early I mean LJ Collier this year there
were shot penny pick I will never
understand and that came so far out of
left field but before that Malik
McDowell I mean before that Frank Clark
you know they even at the top of in
second rounds they are very d-line heavy
I think they look for a certain type of
athlete on day three they'll bet on an
athlete over a proven product so I'm
with you I think they're a very tough
team to figure out they take players
that we don't even have draftable grades
on sometimes in the fifth or sixth round
or they convert players offensive line
to D line vice-versa D line to AU line
Seattle is a very very tough team yep
absolutely are all right Anthony [ __ ]
loser wants to know guys where is Nyjah
Harris as a prospect now he looks like
someone who could be in every down back
but is that true
I like naw J I've been round two I have
him right behind JK Dobbins which is
like running back five for me which is a
damn good place to be because that's
like second-round pick maybe early third
I think that's great for Harris he's
gonna get helped by low wear and tear a
lot like Josh Jacobs did last year I
don't think he always runs as physical
as he is to his size but he's looked
more out
this year that I previously gave him
credit for yeah and he's catching the
ball well too I think we saw that last
week so I have him as my number four
running back right now and probably
towards that second round area
I think his stock is rising though he
won't have the wear and tear like you
mentioned Matt and I I just I really
like the way he's catching the ball out
of the backfield I think if we can show
that show a little bit more versatility
we've seen big backs like Derek Henry go
early too so I think if he can show a
little bit more versatility and
athleticism he's definitely gonna keep
rising I don't know if he can get into
the first round just because the other
three running backs there in front of
him I think having two running backs in
the first round is maybe gonna be hard
to do but Nadja harris I really like the
way he's playing yeah I love naxi I look
at the player and I think he could do
whatever you ask of him that's catch the
ball pass protect obviously he's a great
runner between the tackles on the
outside as well he's got very good speed
for a 230 pound back the only running
back said I would have over him right
now in mellow I think it was just the
same for you would be swift Jonathan
Taylor and etes en right now and I think
Harris is a guy that can climb
I really do he's a lock as a top five
back for me I think he's one of those
runners that'll go on day two and
everyone will be talking about him in
fantasy non-stop because he's one of the
most productive players in the league so
I love the player and I think he'll be
very very successful yeah big fans
alright last question from the sir
crunchy in the last 10 to 15 years or so
how many number one picks can take the
mantle as the best player in their draft
especially when it comes to tank for tua
so not many I think that Miles Garrett
2017 and maybe Jadeveon Clowney 2014
definitely Andrew Luck in 2012 but since
I started doing this job in 2011 at Br
those would be the only two that were
the best player in the draft that we're
also the first pick yeah and positional
value comes in key there with the first
overall pick a lot of times we're seeing
like the one I have pulled up right now
it's 2013 Eric Fisher not the best
player in that draft that's for sure not
even the best tackle I'm looking at Lane
Johnson down here too but it's a lot of
times it's a quarterback when we're
gonna have a better edge rusher get
drafted a couple spots lower or of
running back or a receiver that's
really making a difference the the top
pick is dominated by edge rushers
quarterbacks sometimes you're gonna
tackle either of you have Jared Goff as
the best player in his class I know I
know
hi Jo Anne Ramsey that year yeah and
even those that would boast as well like
that class was really pretty loaded when
you look at it I mean at least top-heavy
Laremy Tunsil was in there as well a lot
of the good Chiefs players came from
this draft too yeah when you look down I
mean the last 15 years there's so many
quarterbacks and like you said matt said
this that Andrew Luck was a no brainer
of course for a lot of people but I
don't know anyone that had Baker
Mayfield that's the number one player I
don't know anyone that had Kyler Murray
I mean we liked Kyler but we had him
like what 7th 8th something like that
miles Garrett is the one Myles Guerra is
definitely the one and that one's
hilarious to me because if my homes are
Watson went number one you go damn well
the bet they look like the bed and I
love Myles Gary
I think Myles Guerra is rare but that
class had superstar talents with mahomes
Watson and Myles Garrett so that's a
really funny one to me
yeah the Eric Fisher one is is obviously
not pretty for a lot of reasons
Jake long is an interesting one 2008 I
think a lot of people thought he was the
best player in that class right I had
Calvin Johnson and joke okay yeah oh
wait here's a funny story from my
history 2008 I have my own little
independent blog someone got mad at me
and hacked it and deleted my ranking so
I don't have my 2008 ranking I remember
this they're not available on the
Internet you can't find them so I have
2007 i have 2009 2008 doesn't exist the
hacker yeah r.i.p Bart's indeed am this
is a great he's not smear a dead guy's
reputation more than I already have okay
that is our actual show we will be back
Monday Connor and I will be coming at
you Monday afternoon because we are
actually home this weekend which is
gonna be very very weird but yeah be
here and then next week we fly to London
I'm not working I can't wait yeah yeah
you can go for that one but it's gonna
be a blast so just a reminder the Monday
show next week will be coming to you in
the afternoon
recapping everything from the college
football NFL weekend there it is boys
don't forget follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at stick to football